it's hard to say on the basis of that
particular story but i have to say i
thought it was most appalling load of uh
a sexist misogynist tripe and i uh
immediately got in touch with angela and
we had a a very friendly
exchange and you know if we ever find
who is responsible for it we'll
i don't know what we'll do with them but
we'll be the terrors of the earth but
you know it's totally intolerable that
kind of thing
another story that hasn't gone away over
the last few days is the fine you
received for breaking covert laws
speculation more fines could come
speculation that sue grey's report could
be devastating for the government as
well is there any circumstance in which
you would look at those reports and go
okay fair enough i'll quit well i tell
you what nick there's absolutely no
circumstances in which i'm gonna comment
on that uh before the thing is is
complete and what we're doing here is is
looking at the incredible efforts of uh
the fans of uh berry football club to
get their their club going again it's a
real privilege to be here i congratulate
the local mp james daley on the on the
work that uh he has put into it i
congratulate everybody involved uh the
vision of the the fans the people have
got together
to get this get this stadium back up and
running again and the facilities are
great what it's but it's part of what we
want to do is to help uh fans across the
country uh with the independent review
that we've uh that we've we've got going
on under uh under tracy crouch uh so
that we have a a regulator and in the
first time uh in in
decades and decades an independent
regulator of football uh will help fans
to stick up for their interests and
stick up for the interests of of
historic clubs not just like black berry
but others
across the country and i'm i'm proud of
the role that the government was able to
uh play in this we played a small role
we used the uh the community ownership
funds but this has really been led by
the fans and i i congratulate them how
quickly are you going to put that
independent regulator into place when
are you going to start making that
difference you watch you hope you have
to hold your your breath nick and just
by you contain your impatience it's been
decades without one
but i'm hopeful we will be able to make
uh rapid legislative progress but we'll
just have to wait is that months is it
years because that's what football fans
want i know they do
when this is going to come into play
we're going as fast as we possibly can
and uh you're going to have to contain
your own patience but tracy's just
concluded her uh her review i think it's
the right thing to do uh if you if you
look at the the the emotion uh the
commitment that fans have to uh to to
clubs up and down the country it's it's
the right thing to do to to help them
and to give these clubs a future can
actually about the the local elections
many in your party seem to be braced for
pretty bad results next week potentially
losing 800 seats across england how bad
is it going to be and is there anything
you can do to turn it around we are as
you would expect uh were fighting for
every possible vote and i think the case
is is very very clear it is conservative
councils that charge you less it's labor
councils uh that have record uh council
taxes and we're the party that does more
to empty your bins uh
does more to fix potholes i think i'm
right in saying uh and you know you can
fact check this if you want but i think
that conservative councils
do four times as many potholes or fill
in four times as many uh potholes as uh
as labour councils
what we believe in fundamentally is
delivering value for money and getting
on with the job that's what conservative
councillors do up and down the country
they do a fantastic job and we're going
to be uh campaigning right up until
after pearling day some of your mps are
a bit worried that things going on at
westminster and the partygate saga is
having an impact on your vote do you
still think you're an asset to the party
when it comes to i think the asset that
we have is the uh the dynamism energy
and effort that conservative councillors
put in up and down the land to
delivering better services based on the
sound conservative principle of taxpayer
value and
they run councils more efficiently i
think in my own borough in uh in
hillingdon which i represent i think of
the work that conservative council has
put in uh to use council tax sparingly
on things that really matter to people
cutting waste doing things like actually
opening libraries keeping libraries open
supporting facilities and uh and making
sure that they deliver value for money
that's what this election's about let me
just quickly try that one again though
are you an asset to your party in this
election i believe that the greatest
asset i'm not denying that i think the
greatest asset that the uh that the
conservatives have uh are conservative
values and the uh the way that
conservative councillors up and down the
country uh deliver
taxpayer value better services more
potholes filled in
more
bins more recycling than labour councils
that's what really matters and i think
that's what people uh will be focused on
and uh and we'll be fighting uh for
everybody right up till pearly day and
just finally president macron's been
re-elected is that good news for the uk
i think it's uh very important that we
have in uh paris uh a president of the
french republic who can
be relied upon when it comes to some of
the most important international issues
and particularly when you look at what's
been going on in ukraine it's not right
for
friendly governments to comment on
elections in in neighbouring countries
but
what i can certainly say is that it is
very very important that emanuel and i
have been able to work closely together
on ukraine over the last few weeks and
months we share a very common very
similar
perspective
and the the unity of the of the west the
unity of nato
has been absolutely vital for the
stance we've taken against uh putin and
that will now continue i'm very very
reassured by that